uh
welcome to the l.a times festival of
books this session is history american
milestones i'm your moderator john
weiner i teach american history at uc
irvine and i write for the nation
magazine now celebrating
its 150th anniversary as america's
oldest weekly
this magnificent 260 page issue is
available in its entirety for free on
the website thenation.com
so for our panel today uh
you know the rules
cell phones
on or off
uh book signing will that be before or
after the session
we have a good group
yes we have a good one okay our format
today i get to ask the first question to
each author we'll have about 10 minutes
for an answer then i'll ask a follow-up
for maybe two or three minutes for a
response
panelists will have uh time to talk to
each other uh if they want and then
we'll open it up to questions from the
floor
first we'll start with
richard reeves of course he's received
dozens of awards for his work in print
television and film he's published more
than 20 books they've been translated
into more than a dozen languages
including chinese and thai
his books include president kennedy
profile of power it's now considered the
authoritative work uh on the subject
it's won several national awards it was
named best non-fiction book of the year
by time book of the year by washington
monthly richard of course also a
columnist his column appeared in more
than 150 newspapers and websites
uh from 1979 to 2014.
his new book is officially published
april 21st the day after tomorrow but we
have copies here
it's called infamy the shocking story of
the japanese american internment in
world war ii please welcome back to the
la times festival of books richard
reeves
so
my question yes i have a question for
you
this world war ii internment of japanese
americans 120 000
uh people two-thirds of them uh citizens
mostly from california sent mostly to
manzanar which is out in owens valley if
you go to a mammoth you drive past the
site
these were people who were not charged
with any crime much less found guilty
nevertheless they were
imprisoned for four years of world war
ii when i teach about manzanar at uc
irvine students have two questions and
they're the questions i'd like to pose
for you how could this have happened
and
what was it like for the japanese
americans who lived in manzanar for for
for uh three or four years
this is what your book is about well the
how it happened is that it has happened
again and again
uh through american history starting
with
obviously the native americans
uh the tories the people who supported
the
revolution who didn't support the
revolution sided with the british were
killed or driven off their lands
and on and on uh through american
history as each immigrant group
was kind of pulled into the country for
labor the chinese
uh to build the railroads the eastern
europeans for the steel
industry northern europeans for farming
and we knew all along and
there was great deal of hatred prejudice
uh that they weren't like us
until they were us
and all of the people in this room come
from
uh come from those people so that it
it has happened again and again and i
tend to
write books there was a second question
how was it
how would you like living in a horse
stable
in santa anita or tanfaran for months
and then being transferred into tar
paper shacks
without plumbing
without heat without
cooking facilities
in the most barren parts of america
where the 10 relocation centers were
places no one had ever lived before
or ever would again tule lake in
california
was a lava bed
manzanar was built on the up
dried up remains
of owens of
owens lake
one of the kids from l.a who
went
found out she was coming to tule
uh packed they were allowed to bring
only what they could carry which usually
meant two
suitcases but she made sure to pack a
bathing suit because she was going to
thule lake without knowing there had not
been water in tule lake for 500 years
the
and
as i said i i guess i write books in
batches i wrote
a trilogy of presidential biographies of
of kennedy
nixon and reagan
and the last book i did before this
uh
was about the berlin airlift and i wrote
that book because of abu ghraib i
these were the better angels of our
nature at that time as as lincoln said
and i wrote the book because i did not
feel that the america i grew up in
and the america i'm hopelessly in love
with
uh was the same as abu ghraib
then as things escalated that was the
angel side
of america i decided i wanted to write
i decided i wanted to keep muslims out
of concentration camps that's what i was
thinking
i wanted to write a book about the dark
history
of america which was dramatized
in the in these uh called relocation
camps
or euphemistically as pioneer colonies
uh
and the
the beginning of the book really is
about the the toxic mix
of fear and of racism
of greed
and
fear racism green
greed
put out because
the
californians led by the attorney general
of the state a man named darryl warren
uh
wanted the land
the fishing boats at that time japanese
accounted for 40
of
the agriculture in the state of
california
of course when they were sent to the
camps their bank accounts were frozen
so that they then lost all their land to
foreclosure
to their caucasian neighbors
which is what in many ways was all about
the
the the first driver was the press
including the newspaper
that paid the rent for this room
uh to say nothing of the hurst papers
both here in la and in san francisco
uh who felt
although they got the line from earl
warren that a [ __ ] is a [ __ ]
and you can't trust them you can't tell
them apart and we've got to to lock them
all up and the villains this is a book
it's not a book about japanese
it's a book about americans on both
sides of the barbed wire
as john mentioned
two-thirds of the people incarcerated
they were not interned
that's a legal firm meaning you're an
alien two-thirds of them were american
citizens
born in the usa their parents the issei
could not no oriental could become a
citizen of the united states
between the after the oriental exclusion
act of 1924
uh until the japanese were allowed to
apply for naturalization in 1952
after they had spent the better part or
some of them
of their lives in in prisons
so that on the one side of the fence the
villains
are people we revere
from the the the outro the fear that the
press much of it made up
uh the battle of los angeles was one of
the famous
battles of world war ii you may remember
when after 12 hours of firing shells
we still missed the enemy which was a
navy weather balloon
so that people were terrified the press
was feeding that
politicians as always would follow the
press
and among
the people who come out as villains in
this book
are franklin roosevelt
who signed the order putting the
japanese
into these camps
and
a strange fellow roosevelt great hero
but also a believer in things like
eugenics
and he felt that the japanese were 2000
years
behind caucasians
we learned that wasn't true
uh
two uh two thousand years behind because
of the shape of their skulls
so he wanted to institute a national
program to change the shape of their
skulls over two
so they wouldn't be
uh
so aggressive
the germans he wanted them all cast
castrated
uh
the earl warren was the attorney general
of california
and he was the one who sold
the idea of putting these people into
prison
to
to the press
he made up maps showing how close
japanese americans live to military
bases to airfields to ports
to fuel depots
to power lines without mentioning of
course
they had been there for 50 years
before the bases were built or the power
lines
uh were sent
and er warren's theory which he
articulated many times
in the press and in uh
before congress
was that the fact that there was never a
single act of japanese
sabotage in world war ii
uh that was proof
that they were planning a big one and it
would all be directed from tokyo
roger baldwin
the founder of the aclu
forbid aclu attorneys he was a friend of
roosevelt he wanted to protect the
president
forbid any aclu attorneys to file suits
based which mentioned race
as being a factor
uh in all of this of course race was the
factor
to many people after all we were
fighting germany
and italy at the same time
and if we did the same thing to them as
we did to the 120 000 japanese
on the west coast we would have had to
build prison camps for 50 million people
including many of us
in this room
uh the but baldwin would not let the
aclu attorneys
mention race
and
uh
the young ones the the real civil
libertarians quit and the aclu almost
collapsed over that
walter lippman
then the greatest columnist in
country best known columnist most
intellectual columnist
in the best papers
met with her warren
for a long lunch
and then repeated almost word for word
in two columns
warren's arguments why the
why the japanese should be
putting concentration camps
two days after lipman's column
roosevelt signed he gave him real cover
with liberals
roosevelt signed
executive order 9066
which put the the japanese behind
japanese americans behind barbed wire
edward r murrow who was from the state
of washington
gave a series of speeches
arguing that when the west coast was
bombed by the japanese
if you looked up a lot of them would be
wearing university of washington
sweatshirts or wearing university of
washington
rings
and finally uh
the cartoonist of the most liberal
newspaper in the country pm in new york
did a series of cartoons the most famous
of which
showed buck-toothed japanese
uh coming down the whole coast
and picking up dynamite and standing
with telescopes looking for orders from
tokyo
his name was
dr seuss
dr seuss
dr seuss all right
and i'll just finish the one thing
the living conditions
were horrible by any
uh
by any standards they were worse than
prisoner of war camps and on the other
hand
the americans really deal with problems
we
by moving on
and we did move on and there's no doubt
in my mind
that
brown v topeka
which was written by the same earl
warren
desegregating
public facilities in the south
was a direct
effect redemption
of the
of the incarceration
uh in his oral history berkeley does
gigantic oral histories of california
governors in the sixth day of
questioning
emilia fry the woman doing the
questioning
uh at berkeley
finally said to warren after talking
about all this triumphs
and i want to talk now about 19 what
happened in 1942.
warren broke into tears walked out of
the room and never came back
richard reeves
thank you
and we'll have a chance to come back to
this in the question period uh i would
have thought it was impossible at this
point to come up with a new story about
abraham lincoln and the civil war
but scott martel has succeeded scott is
an editorial writer for the la times
he's the author of four other books
including blood passion the ludlow
massacre and class war in the american
west his new book is the madman and the
assassin the strange life of boston
corbett the man who killed john wilkes
booth please welcome back to the la
times festival of books scott martel
so scott last tuesday was the 150th
anniversary of the assassination of
abraham lincoln everybody knows who
killed him john wilkes booth but the man
who killed john wilkes booth would seem
to be the ultimate footnote to history
if if a grad student had told me they
wanted to write a phd dissertation in
history on
on
your subject your topic i would have
said it's impossible he was famous for
10 minutes not even 15 minutes
maybe
you know it would be nice to know about
them but you'll never be able to get
enough material but you have done it you
have found this guy's life is immensely
revealing about a lot of things in
american
history in the 19th century starting
with
the civil war lincoln prison camps but
also religion in the 19th century
politics in the 19th century
but you didn't know any of that you
didn't know how
it would be possible to write this when
you started it what made you think there
was a whole book that could be written
about boston core but and how were you
able to get enough material on this
obscure guy to write this excellent book
i didn't really know i could at first
the way i got onto this i just finished
my previous book which is about the guy
who went to find john paul jones's body
in paris had gone missing for a hundred
years uh beginning with the french
revolution
and i finished with that i was looking
off another idea i had a couple of dry
holes and my editor chicago review press
uh sent me an email and said have you
ever heard of boston corbett's like now
he emailed back well he castrated
himself and killed john wilkes booth
this is the one thing if people know
anything about boston corporate that's
the that's the only thing they know he
castrated and i didn't even know that
much so my immediate reaction was you
know i'm a journalist i i can run with
that
the rest of it almost doesn't matter
right
but it wasn't quite that easy uh it took
a lot of digging around before we knew
we had enough material for a book and
this happened i had about a year to do
this book it was a quick turnaround
because of the the sesquicentennial
um so i did a couple of quick uh looks
and research as a 40 years in daily
journalism you know how to like scramble
quickly
and i discovered that uh
in 1880 1878
uh he had
done a uh homestead in kansas that he
moved to kansas well after the war and
while he was out there he was born in
new york i'm sorry born in london moved
to new york raised in new york city so
he was a city kid and he went to kansas
to be a farmer and that worked out about
as well as you would expect it would um
so there's no safety net at that point
so he was starving to death out there
and he had spent uh nearly five months
in the andersonville prison camp if
you're familiar with that but it was an
absolutely horror show of a place and
survived it but it ruined it had
physically ruined itself
so he decided to apply for a government
pension military pension and to do that
you have to file all these affidavits
and get people to write affidavits about
what you were like when you were healthy
which is before the war
uh
about the nature of the injuries people
who knew him in andersonville and what
his what his physical life was like now
at in the current time so that was a
treasure trove of material the pension
bureau records in the national archives
and this is a bit of a spoiler alert so
buy the book anyway and read the last
chapter
corbett disappeared from an insane
asylum
and a few years later a guy emerged uh
pretending to be boston corbett he was
selling snake oil or something down in
texas area
and so he was like writing letters you
know get me declared uninsane or sane
whatever the phrasing would be
and
uh the guy who had been appointed
guardian of boston corbett's estate
realized
she took a little time realized this
wasn't the real boston corbett so they
began he began filing complaints with
the government they began investigating
this guy and this big investigation came
up on well who is the real boston
corbett and this lawyer named george
huron uh went back he traveled all the
way to new jersey at one point to talk
to people who knew corbett in the
earlier part of his life
and so there's a treasure trove material
from from that stuff and as corbett's
guardian he had all of corbett's letters
so there's uh several hundred letters
that people had written to corbett so
you had the the pension file affidavits
you know that investigatory stuff people
you know i knew him when he was in new
york and 20 and it was healthy when he
worked for me um these little stories
and his ten minutes of fame was actually
more like three hours
okay he he was an early celebrity
so you read the newspapers from that era
and there were stories all over the
country about boston and cora most of
them wrong but people were tracking him
during that time and as that happened
there were these interesting memoirs and
recollections you know people who had
been in andersonville with him you know
they'd write their story while they're
experienced with boston corbett so as a
historian as historians yourselves you
know once you find where that little
that thread is to pull i was
amazed at how much material was was you
know out there to get on him except for
his early life i sort of struck out on
his london years you you told the la
times in an interview that you found
yourself sympathetic to boston core but
i wonder why
why that was and whether you thought
that's important to making the book a
success
yeah whenever if you go online and look
at boston corbett you essentially see
the guy was a crazy religious zealot i
mentioned the self-castration uh he
his wife had died while he was young uh
he was still a healthy young male after
a religious conversion it's all in the
book i'll give you all the details now
um but he you know he had a sexual young
man's libido and he was a street
preacher and his libido kept he thought
kept getting in the way of his uh
proselytizing so he took a pair of
scissors one day and
yeah i know i know
uh
but then he went to we are on live tv
here scott so
it's the family out there looking for a
demonstration it's the family the family
hour and even worse it's dinner time in
the east coast sorry about that
but but but after doing this corbett
went out to dinner and then he went to a
prayer meeting
and then he came home and decided he got
to see a doctor and spent a month in a
hospital in boston um
and that's sort of the ludicrous extreme
of his of his religious faith but he
also thought this is where he began not
a person of faith myself but i began to
build sympathy for him he genuinely
thought that if he could live every
minute of every hour of every day of
every week of his life he could lead the
perfect christian existence and the way
he did that was he was living in new
york he was working as a silk hat
finisher making no money and he had been
saved by some early day salvation army
folks he was a alcoholic after his wife
died
so he would go in the streets and find
drunks in the streets pick him up bring
him back to his room right his room and
his tenement
and dry him out clean him up get him
sober get him a job
push him out go find another one and he
lived his life like that and you have to
admire somebody who's got that kind of
devotion to not you know saying i'm a
christian but to actually living that
day today
so good to like the guy
thank you scott martel
[Applause]
edward larson is winner of the pulitzer
prize in history for his book summer for
the gods the scopes trial and america's
continuing debate over science and
religion he's university professor of
history at pepperdine university where
he holds the hugh and hazel darling
chair in law he's also a famous teacher
about the history and theory of
evolution he received the richard
russell teaching award from the
university of georgia his new book which
we're talking about today is the return
of george washington 1783-1780
please welcome to the la festival of
books ed larson
thank you
so ed scott
wrote a book about a person no one had
ever heard of you've written about a
book about a person everyone thinks they
know everything about
i looked in amazon how many books are
there with the name george washington in
the title
55
261.
[Applause]
you have written one more you are a
brave man and we we salute you for that
most historians would regard this as
impossible finding something new to say
about george washington but you have
succeeded magnificently in this book his
role in shaping the constitution not a
small thing yet somehow neglected by
55 261 other historians how did you come
up with this and and what exactly is new
in your book
well
thank you
the reason
i'm glad you agree there's something new
there
i
sort of what i do with most of my books
the book you mentioned the one when the
pulitzer prize the scopes trial book uh
fit that standard what i
do is i try to take a subject that
people know a lot about or at least
think they know a lot about
that's widely known and find
gaps in the historical research so with
the scopes book for example as much as
we all knew it from the wonderful play
and great mute great
movie inherit the wind
and from reading only yesterday another
classic book of the 1930s
no historian had ever written a book
about the scopes trial and so i was able
to bring historical methods to it and
unpack it as it
as a historian would and two of my
biggest fans became bob lee and jerry
lawrence who wrote inherit the wind and
said no we weren't talking about it the
scopes trial really we were really
talking about mccarthyism and we were
using that vehicle and you've captured
this perfectly
and so i followed that up with the book
on the on the galapagos islands i
figured if i had to go to dayton
tennessee 17 times for research i'd
rather go to the galapagos islands 17
times for research but i dealt not
focused on on darwin
work there but all the other scientific
re work done and a lot of it i
researched right in this building
because this is named for for for um
alan hancock and alan hancock and the
early usc was the main funder along with
stanford of research down in the
galapagos islands and allen hancock
would take his ship the velaro down
there every year and so i got to read
about that and learn all about that and
then similarly with the
with the 1800 book the 1800 election
book because no one had ever unpacked
the 1800 election book as a as a current
event
such as making of the president 1960 and
doing it that way rather than in a broad
scope
looking for gaps in the literature in
their historical literature was
and that's how i came to the washington
book now i never thought i'd write a
book about george washington but what it
was for years i've taught american
history at university of georgia for
years and
when you teach american history as a
survey course you spend a couple days on
the american revolution and it's all
about george washington
and then you spend a couple days talking
about the confederation period and you
learn how the country was going to hell
in a hand basket how everything was
falling apart how the british hadn't
evacuated the forts in the west and were
pushing in and how the frontiers people
were making deals with the spanish out
of new orleans to to flip that way and
how um vermont was conspiring with the
british to to to leave america and join
the join british canada and of course
shea's rebellion which frightened
washington greatly in massachusetts and
the radical printing of paper money in
places like rhode island and and georgia
where literally there was chaos and then
when you see the native americans armed
by the british and the spanish moving
back in and retaking most of georgia
literally the country was falling apart
and if you look more closely each of the
states were sovereign unto themselves
because we were under an articles of
confederation
which gave no power to the central
government there was no effective
central government they couldn't raise
taxes they couldn't have an army they
couldn't
effectively run the country and each
state was competing against each other
state um to aggrandize itself and trying
to export its taxes into its neighbor
causing the collapse of the whole and a
great sense among europeans that they
were just going to re
um re-annex the colonies
again we talk about that and then of
course we go to the constitution and the
presidency and it's all about washington
again but in that middle two days when
you're talking about the collapse of the
confederation you hear nothing about
george washington he disappears they say
oh he went home to his his
mount vernon
and was a farmer again and even if you
read biographies of washington even
great ones even the multi-volume ones
such as by flexner or ron chernov's
great biography when they get to this
period
they say he went home to mount vernon
they talk about him as a farmer well
there is something to say about him as a
farmer he was a very resourceful
interesting farmer that turned a plate
out plantation into a profitable one by
his work
but he was much more than that i said
could it be possible the greatest
celebrity in the world the most famous
person in america the person who served
nine years without pay or leave leading
the american army during the revolution
the person who sent soldiers to their
death who he was very close to his
officers many of them died
a person who'd done all this who
sacrificed everything for the cause of
the independence of america and also was
motivated more than by power more than
by money
motivated by a desire to leave a legacy
and his legacy was as he always called
it
a government of the people where there
was no
republican governments in the world they
were all monarchies or some sort of
dictatorships and he wanted to create a
government of the people he saw it all
collapsing
he and he wouldn't care he'd just sit
out in mount vernon and do nothing so i
went back was fortunate enough to get a
fellowship from mount vernon to actually
live in mount vernon for a while went
through all of his papers went through
all of his writings went through
everyone who visited all the people
visiting mount vernon to find out what
he was during that period and it was a
little bit like that famous book about
eisenhower the hidden hand presidency he
didn't want to put himself forward
because it would look like he would be
craving this job of running the country
a job he had retired from the cincinnati
story and he really didn't want to be
president but he wanted
to leave a legacy he wanted he believed
he was an enlightened he was a product
of the enlightenment he believed in
government of the people he believed in
individual liberty he believed in
private property and he believed in the
sovereignty of america and he was
engaged from the day he went back to the
day he came back was inaugurated he was
engaged even before he went back with
his circular letter to the states which
was what the most widely known document
at the time in fighting for a more
perfect union a consolidated government
a national government where the national
government was sovereign and with the if
i could so what i was able to follow
with the meetings that were happening at
mount vernon he would have dozens of
people coming to mount vernon
james madison spent the months before
going up to philadelphia living at mount
vernon
george washington was involved in every
meeting when the virginia plan was
created and during the constitutional
convention he working with
madison working with morris working with
franklin working with the others
he was orchestrating the creation of a
constitution that could get passed and
then during the ratification process he
was involved in that in every state so
that sort of story hadn't been unpacked
before that's the story i thought today
when we we where when that old when our
constitution and our government is
challenged this was an important story
because he had strong goals but he was
also working with all different peoples
he knew how to compromise he was a
retail as well as a wholesale politician
he had a goal and he produced
well i'll just close by saying one
comment often people describe james
madison as the architect of the
constitution
that could well be true he certainly
drafted large portions of it along with
say governor morrison and um
james wilson
but if james madison was the architect
of the constitution then i say that
george washington was the general
contractor
and if any of you have ever built a
house or put an extension on does it
look more like what the general
contractor have in mind who gets it done
and that was george washington's role
and it was just it was a delight and a
privilege and and to me more than i ever
expected when i when i jumped into this
project i didn't even know if it would
lead to a book i thought it might lead
just to an article
but it's an exciting story and gave me a
new vision of what sort of a leader
george washington was
edward larson
so there's a
there's a dark side to the uh
constitutional convention of course
that's slavery and washington of course
was was a slave owner uh
the word slavery famously does not
appear in the constitution but it's
present in
three different uh uh places the the
three fifth clause about how uh slaves
would be counted for
uh representation in the house
uh there's a fugitive slave clause in
the original constitution and there's a
provision that the slave trade couldn't
be restricted
for a period of years
what was
so your argument is washington is a key
figure in the final form of the
constitution what was his role in the
debate over slavery at the
constitutional convention and in those
those final compromises
he was very much part of those
compromises and i lay those all out in
the book i would add a fourth that
people forget is the electoral college
wouldn't exist but for slavery it was a
way
the people who designed the um
who designed their constitution
governor morris and and james wilson
wanted to have everybody vote but the
southern states wouldn't let the slaves
vote and they knew that half their
people were slaves and they'd be out
voted by the north and so the electoral
college was a way to give the states
disproportionate representation
in choosing a president and of course it
worked with a series of southern
presidents during the period leading up
to the civil war so there were four and
washington was a part of all of them uh
he was troubled by slavery
which makes him different in a way than
jefferson and madison he ended up
freeing his slaves
at his death he put it in his will his
final decision when he's dying of which
will to say this is the one we're going
to use and he then tears up one and
gives the one that frees his slaves he
had been pushed during the revolution by
he was very close to his aides
during the revolution he was always
close very loyal very close he had a he
had a he was he was a man who had very
close friends and he was very loyal to
them but hamilton uh uh lafayette
probably more than any and henry
lawrence of south carolina all took a
very strong position against slavery and
pleaded with him during the revolution
to free his slaves as as a symbol to
everyone else and he agonized over that
decision now
he
he realized how important it was to
keeping the union together and the union
ended up becoming i believe his main
concern now benjamin franklin to his
credit who takes a much bigger lead in
trying to oppose slavery um and he goes
along with the constitution and his
justification and he met often with
washington and this may have been
involved somewhat but franklin who was a
leader creator of the first abolitionist
society in america he said if we don't
get a union there never will be slavery
ended in the south and uh because uh
patrick henry was trying to lead the
south out into a separate confederation
that would have enshrined slavery
forever they thought and washington may
have been involved somewhat but
certainly he was involved in working out
the compromises because he believed that
the south would never stay in without
those compromises
thank you ed larson
uh we have a chance here for the
panelists to talk to each other ask
questions uh for each other our form
right here our leaders tell us should be
conversational would anyone like to
converse
well actually i've got a question that
sort of came up did you get the sense
that washington's approach to slavery
was based in his personal morality or
because he stood to gain if he freed his
slaves he lost his free labor
washington was washington had inherited
a variety of slaves working on mount
vernon but most of his slaves actually
came through his wife he married very
well those of you who have he never
thought he'd be we all did
he never thought he'd be a wealthy man
um he thought he'd um thought he'd have
to work for a living and that's why he
developed a trade and then by his
brother's death he ended up inheriting
land but then he married the richest
widow in the state who brought many many
slaves with him with her
he couldn't free those slaves anyway
but i think deeper down he could have
kept his slaves and made them employees
of some sort
i think he could have worked that out
individually but in the larger sense he
was living in a slave state with the
slave culture and many of the southern
states they re oddly enough the only
reason they south carolina probably
fought in the war is when they said we
protecting our liberty it was protecting
our liberty to own slaves because
england was going to end it and so he
knew he was dealing with a with a system
that pulled together and i
deep down he believed that the whole
system as it was at that time would
collapse without it
and that it would take time to make any
changes and so he ended up could have
freed his slaves during his lifetime but
he ended up doing it as deathbed and
it's better than nothing it's better
than what jefferson madison did but it's
a far cry from what we should expect
from him and it's a far cry from what we
had with hamilton or what we had with
with franklin or what we had with
hancock or we had with others who
actually did make that sacrifice and
didn't have
slaves coming up on that question to
today
how christian was
washington how christian were his
buddies and how christian was the
constitution
excellent george washington
stopped attending church during the
revolutionary war
um he would go when he was president but
he always made a point of leaving before
communion the minister of the church he
preached at was the great bishop white
of philadelphia believed that george
washington did not believe in the
christian revelation um before the
revolution of course he was the local he
was he had a large plantation and he and
he had a he was on the vestry as
everybody in the in a in a large
plantation would hold but
from everything i've been able to read
george washington like most of the other
founding fathers was
some sort of a unitarian to deist he had
a profound sense of providence and that
profound sense of providence and belief
in god
was critical to his his whole world view
so he wasn't like governor morris for
example he was certainly wasn't an
atheist or an agnostic he profoundly
believed in providence
um would probably put him somewhere in
the category of a unitarian that would
that would be true of jefferson he was
probably more unitarian than a deist
same with franklin at the end um john
adams when you rattle through most of
these people they come out somewhere
because they're they're they tend to be
children the enlightenment and if you
want to get a christian during this
period who was important you'd look at
witherspoon or john jay
what is
uh your book on
i was fascinated by both of your books
i've long been fascinated by your work
on the by the whole japanese internment
and i've thought about
how warren could have gone through this
do you think that warren at the time
believed what he was doing or do you
think at the time that he was angling
because this was a great step to higher
office and he ends up becoming what the
most popular governor probably in
california history
i think that
he acted
not as a believer but as a as a
politician
the this is what the public wanted
people were afraid
and he rode the back of that hatred to
the governorship
against colbert olsen
who had been
as it were less vigorous in
condemning japanese americans i want to
mention one thing about the word
internment
which
if you deal with people who live
in this world internment is something
that is done with aliens enemy aliens
are intern during wartime
so while the word
internment
has lived on as what happened with the
japanese
in fact for most of them they were not
aliens most of them were american
citizens
and they were simply jailed
not interned
i had no rights no charges no nothing i
i have another question for scott you
say that
that boston corbett in your book you say
he was a celebrity after he killed john
wilkes booth
we're very familiar with the term
celebrity in our society but i imagine
it must have meant something very
different in 1865
not really
which has kind of surprised me kind of
surprised me
we think of celebrity these days in
terms of social media you know twitter
you know something happens in 30 seconds
the whole world knows what happened uh
we were sort of at the early stages of
that by the time of the civil war
because the telegraph already existed
and it's really kind of my research is
kind of fascinating
when
when booth was killed within a day or
two boston corporate's name started
showing up in newspapers you can go all
of you can go online to a library of
congress loc.gov they do this
chronicling america site which is
scanned in digitized newspapers from the
early days of the country to 1922 i
think is the shut off and you can you
know throw in date parameters on it so
you throw in um
and just throw in the year of 1865
january 1 through december 31st and plug
in boston corbett's name and january
nothing february nothing march nothing
end of april he's all over the country i
mean so it was like anybody who had any
access to a newspaper or lived in a
settled village area where there was a
local local paper and a telegraph knew
who he was within 48 hours at the time
he killed uh booth it was kind of
fascinating because it was very
obviously torn times
to the north he was a hero he killed he
avenged lincoln he was the the killer of
the assassin to the south he killed a
hero
so he was getting all these hate letters
from people um he was paranoid to begin
with i don't like i'm not a psychologist
but he had mental illness and it seems
like paranoia
perhaps bipolar uh so he had a deathly
fear of secret organizations the booth
brothers were involved in some secret
societies and he thought the secret
societies are coming to get him
um so
if he acted out he carried a gun
everywhere so he'd be in a public venue
and he put the gun on the table he shut
shut down a court proceeding testing one
day pulling his guns out
and every time this happened it zips
around the country so he had his like
mentioned earlier with you 10 minutes
versus three hours you know people were
following what was happening to him and
then he finally went crazy in 1887
and it started all over again and then
disappeared from the insane aside a year
later and it started all over again so
just so the echo effects of early social
media celebrities and just say a word
about what might have been the cause of
his mental illness his paranoia
uh
hard to diagnose from 150 years on but
you're familiar with the phrase mad as a
hatter uh yeah he was a silky mercury he
was a silk hat finisher by trade and
they used mercury before they knew what
the impact was on mercury on the brain
for mercury they used that uh to
compress the felt and form the body of
the hat so he who knows how much of that
stuff he inhaled over the course of his
square as a silk hat finisher so this
man as a hatter
actually refers to the mercury poisoning
an occupational hazard of being a hat
maker
and boston corbett was mad as a hatter
he was
while we're at it as
historians and popular historians
and journalists
i i would ask all of us how has the
internet changed your work
and how is it affecting history
i just pop up quickly on that one my
first book was about the ludlow massacre
in southern colorado 1913 1914 colorado
coalfield war there were two uh
investigations uh one by a congressional
subcommittee another one by the
industrial commission
commission industrial relations
and i had to lay out several hundred
dollars to buy copies of those things uh
nine years ago when i was working on
that book you can go to google books now
and look at it for free
at three in the morning whenever you
insomnia strikes and that's been a huge
change to me anyway
i agree it's made a major change and i
think it's a fundamental change
um
it's
it started of course with with printing
press and then it added when you said
the telegraph and then you telephone but
with the internet it's almost like the
world's connected
and so even though my topics tend to be
back when there of course wasn't any
internet and i have to use archives and
i have to use papers and i have to use
to use letters and all sorts of activity
still there's so much you can get in the
internet and you can call on an expert
so i will email the expert on a on this
particular issue that i'm dealing with
when i'm unpacking slavery i'll i'll go
to the expert on slavery during the
revolutionary period or when i'm dealing
with the ratification ratification i can
go right to uh
pauline and uh meyer in at
at mit and i could ask him a question
and it's sort of i sort of get the
comparison that it's like this world is
becoming more one great big brain and we
can interact in ways our synapses the
internet's not as fast as our own
synapses in our brain but we can collect
the energy well i hope not but it it
does it does collect the information
you're able to access so much more
often books that i would have a long
time getting through interlibrary loan
are right on google books because i'm
dealing with books that are out of
copyright so they're already copied in
there and i can pull them up right away
but you can also contact different
people and you can send ideas out and
get feedback right away and that sort of
networking
is empowering if i think it's empowering
just the work in history
imagine what it's doing in work in
physics or in working in engineering or
working in other areas and it's able to
speed up so tremendously our acquisition
and development of knowledge that to me
as a historian who looks back in history
of ideas in the past
it's almost frightening it must be
working in poetry it must be working in
literature it must be working in so many
areas and i think it's just a dang
exciting time to be alive it is it's
that whole hive mind approach and and
the flip side of that is when you do
google journalists know this if you ask
a question you get an answer you don't
may not necessarily get the full answer
and i think the danger of online
research and you mentioned you go to
archives you have to do the archival
work the the online stuff tells you a
lot and tells you where things are uh
tells you where the pension bureau
records are in my case but you still
have to go and do that work the danger
of the internet is stopping with google
yeah google should be where you start
richard what about you my answer i'll
give it an anecdote
on the day that the new york times
put its entire archive online
i stayed up until three o'clock in the
morning i was writing a book on a
physicist actually ernest rutherford the
great british
physicist
uh he was quite new zealanders would
claim new zealand i'm sorry
the new zealand the member of the
british empire
uh he was very famous in his time i
i don't know if he was as famous as
boston was but he was pretty famous
i sat there
and
using his name
found from 1861 on
every time ernest rutherford was
mentioned
uh
in the new york times reddit
job offers
i finally
went to bed
sometime between three and four at night
my wife woke up said
what did you what have you been doing i
said i just did five months work
yeah yeah that's true all right we have
a few minutes for questions here the
rules as you know are pl the question
period is for questions that's an
interrogatory statement rather than a
declarative statement we have
microphones who's got the microphones
and uh
let us
who has the mic you have the microphone
back there all right and is there a
questioner over there
who's got their hand up here i met and
he does eventually okay here's one
so just following up on that question
about the internet ed
your book wouldn't have been possible
if you hadn't taken the fellowship at
mount vernon to be there with the
original document so that here's a place
where there's a disconnect right oh
absolutely i totally agreed with what
scott said
you cannot
trust
the
wikipedia for
facts it but it can be a tremendously
helpful starting point and to double
check and if you found something and
then you check it on the internet and it
disagrees well then you've got to go a
little closer but for doing the source
of work i think all three of us do we
need to do interviews we need to do
we need to do the hard stuff of going
into archives what the internet can do
is uh some of those documents an
increasing number of them are available
on the internet so they can do that
second you can directly contact other
experts very quickly and get responses
from them when the idea of sending a
letter or making a phone call and then
of course you don't get a very clear
record when you're just talking on the
phone so it has those advantages but
i would never
i never even use a quote from somebody
else's books so if i'm reading a book by
another historian and they take a quote
i have to go back to the original source
because i can't trust exactly how they
quoted it it's not any pejorative to
them it's just they may have cut it out
in some way and dropped ellipses no i
always have to go back to the original
sources but the internet can help you
find those original sources can actually
access some of them and can be drawn on
as a as a critical resource it has
speeded up
how quickly i can do a book that i think
is credible history it is maybe cut the
time just picking a number cut it in
half and let me add one thing about
richard's project on manzanar uh if if
you're interested in the experience of
the people who were imprisoned in
manzanar there are a few memoirs some
very wonderful famous memoirs but the
great majority of the people who were
there
are not found in print archives
they're not in the newspapers and for
that you do have to go someplace like
the japanese american museum downtown
l.a where there's lots of handwritten uh
diary entries and handmade photographs
yes they there's also
well there's a history
like people who served in combat the
adult japanese
rarely ever talked out of shame
about
what had happened
and especially to their own children and
grandchildren
ironically it was the black civil rights
movement which mobilized young japanese
americans to begin to ask their parents
what did you do during the war daddy
and and and at that point
most of the
most of the work began
uh or most of the literature began at
that point
and it was interestingly
it was largely memoir
and it was largely done for young adults
including the most famous
return to manzanar which is required
reading
for students in california
so that
uh it was and also
when the japanese
as it were japanese americans regained
their sense of pride and self-esteem
and decided they were going to tell
their stories a marvelous internet
organization
called thenshow.org d-e-n-s-h-o
which was
founded by
japanese intellectuals and teachers
and has done
thousands of oral histories
uh
on videotape of those people and indexed
them and that's the kind of resource of
course
that didn't exist before the internet
and it didn't exist either before
young people began to
to say what happened what happened
another question about right here
over here okay yes uh richard i just
have a question about the attitude of
the
rest of the country toward the japanese
and and toward the whole interns i grew
up in a neighborhood in the south side
of chicago was all japanese-american i
found out much later that they were
pretty much all from manzanar and they
came to chicago to work
so what was what was the general tenor
of the rest of the i know that west
coast was very
terrible
uh obviously it was a west coast story
in the camps
uh many if you could find a job and the
quakers were the best the american
friend service at finding a job in
another part of the country
uh you could move to that part and the
chicago minneapolis
and indianapolis were the three cities
that most of the young japanese they
were young they were nurses
uh they were secretaries
uh they were accountants however
among the people i interviewed one that
sticks in my mind
was the wife of a couple who moved to
indianapolis he was a certified public
accountant
and she worked as a kind of a chief
clerk
in an organization they lived in
indianapolis for 25 years
and she told me that not a single person
they talked to their friends were
caucasian
uh
had heard of the of the internment
it was and of course if they did hear
the government maintain very tight
control
and they kind of made manzanar look like
grossingers
uh because they would censor all the
pictures and all the words that came out
the most frustrated of people in the
camps was ansel adams the great
photographer and dorothea lange
another great photographer
the
two things frustrated them one
the japanese always that the prisoners
always wanted to put their face best
face forward so they would dress they
would smile and then the government
uh censored the pictures to make sure
that pictures that showed certain parts
of actual life did not appear
during uh during the war so that
in general the answer the question is
people in the rest of the country unless
they happened to have personal contact
didn't know this was happening
just a one foot note to that i'm from
minneapolis i'm glad you mentioned
minneapolis uh the private uh colleges
of minnesota
invited students from ucla and usc to
transfer
uh to macalester college saint
uh
the university of minnesota didn't allow
them uh so a lot of the the japanese
community of of the twin cities actually
started as transfer students invited by
the colleges the japanese americans uh
at this institution were expelled
do we have time for one more
how about right there
right here
well this
yes i'm curious if the
camps
incarceration camps were in such
isolated areas where it'd be difficult
if
the japanese escaped probably to get the
civilization before they were captured
what were the instructions to the guards
and were there any attempted escapes or
successful escape
there probably
was one attempted escape
in all of the all of the ten camps
and
uh
when he got to the railroad train he was
at hart mountain in wyoming
got to the railroad terminal
and suddenly realized that he was not
going to be safe outside
and returned
afterwards
people
the soldiers who are guarding them the
first thing
the first thing the
the
evacuees were told
that they were being put in these camps
to protect them
against the white population
as they reached the camps finally they
realized the machine guns
weren't pointed out they were pointed in
uh the tanks outside weren't pointed out
they were
uh pointed in
so that but there was no real
they were in places where they couldn't
manzanars between two towns lone pine
and independence in california i would
guess the combined population of those
two towns about 800 people
and so there was no way to escape and
even when the government just before
they opened the camps
gave japanese permission to leave the
western states
and if they could get past california
actually get past the sierras
they could they could live as japanese
did in new york or chicago as
as free people
in each case they were met at the
borders of colorado
of arizona
of idaho by armed vigilante mobs which
drove them back
no one would sell them food no one would
sell them water
and they had to return to the california
and the camps
if they hadn't been in the camps yet but
there were no escapes and there were
perhaps
three dozen
shootings
the barbed wire inside
the guard was yelling at him
[Music]
to stop he was too close
and then
he didn't respond the guard shot him
killed him
the guard was court-martialed
and found guilty
well i'm afraid our time is up i want to
thank richard reeves scott martel and ed
larson for a terrific session
what
foreign